[Music]
so much of science culture to me seems
like a holdover from the last century
there is still this formalism that's
involved and and to some degree
scientific formalism is really needed
because the whole point of being a
scientist is if you write a scientific
paper another scientist should be able
to read your paper and set up their
instrument just like yours and do
exactly the same experiment and if
everything goes right they would get the
same result you know point your
telescope at this part of the sky
observe for this long and you're gonna
see the same thing that I did at least
you hope so and this formalism now is
something that we constantly stumble
over because I think scientists have
made the mistake that the formalism is
science
it is a tool it is a part of science and
it's a useful tool but science itself is
an inquiry in its curiosity it is not a
method there is no such real thing as a
scientific method people go about being
a scientist in many different ways with
many different strategies so there
really seems to be this this this sort
of it almost is a rejection as a
scientist of being very emotionally
connected to your work of being able to
convey that to an audience and I think
that you know the word that I come up
with is the idea of celebrating what we
do celebrating science the amazing
accomplishments the amazing system we
have in place that can invent new
technologies that can make new new
discoveries celebrating something as
simple as that there is a field of study
called astrophysics where we're doing
everything from learning what set off
the Big Bang to exploring the moons of
Jupiter these are wonderful things to be
celebrated and yet as scientists we
think that it's it's somehow kind of
where we're blowing our own horn it's
very unseemly to do this and I often run
into scientists that really resist
science communicators like me trying to
help them visualize their science you
know I think about exoplanets planets
around other stars at this moment in
time we know of about 4000 planets going
around other stars in the sky
and we have some data on them the data
is usually just what the mass of the
planet is how big the planet is whether
the planet is solid or gaseous
but so often I run across scientists I
just want to present the graphs of their
data and they get very upset when we
bring in artists very well-informed
artists by the way they work with the
scientists and say well you know with
that size of a planet and that distance
from the star maybe you'd have an
atmosphere maybe would have clouds maybe
it even has water on the surface and we
always say we don't know these things
but this is based on scientific fact you
know a lot of scientists really really
rebel when you try to actually make it
something visual and something emotional
it doesn't seem to really be science if
you let that happen to me science is
going to die unless science becomes
something that everyone can be involved
in it can't just be the purview of a few
privileged people that separate
themselves off from the rest of culture
you know the same thing with art art is
something that isn't just done by
professional artists anyone can draw and
paint and dance and become involved in
the arts and value the arts because of
that and everyone can ask questions and
everyone can wonder why a sunset is red
or wonder what the planet Jupiter is
made of it's not something that should
be cordoned off and made into something
separate from the rest of human life and
I actually think the survival of science
depends on that so as scientists it's up
to us to celebrate what we do to
celebrate the things we're discovering
to celebrate ourselves to actually say
that this is something worth doing to me
science has added so much beauty and
richness to my life and so much emotion
and we start by telling people that you
know come along and see what we're
learning and see how it changes your
life and I mean that your life will be
changed when you learn the things that
we know for the better and then all of a
sudden it's not something just done in
an ivory tower by a few people it's
anybody who can ask a question any child
that says why that whole entirety of
science that whole spectrum has to be
something that professional scientists
curate and and really encourage to grow
[Music]
you